este lunes en cocoa beach a unos
kilómetros del centro espacial kennedy
decenas de espectadores no pudieron
observar con sus binoculares el
lanzamiento de la misión artemis 1 la
falla en el proceso de purga de uno de
los motores causó que éste no se enfriar
a una temperatura aceptable para los
ingenieros de la nasa obligando a
retrasar el evento el proceso de purga
es vital para la seguridad en el
lanzamiento del cohete dado que el
hidrógeno debe circular por la máquina
para acondicionarla al despegue como lo
expresa bill nelson administrador de la
nasa el funcionamiento de la misión es
más complejo de lo que parece
wright
y no lanzaremos hasta que todo esté bien
y creo que es solo ilustrativo decir que
esta es una máquina muy complicada tiene
un sistema muy complejo y todas esas
cosas tienen que funcionar el 2 de
septiembre es la opción que más suena
para la reprogramación de lanzamiento
según the road' neil portavoz de la nasa
esta misión hace parte del programa
artemis moon que pretende que los
humanos vuelvan a pisar la luna luego el
histórico apolo 11 y artemis 1 es la
primera de tres misiones siendo ésta una
prueba lanzando a órbita una cápsula no
tripulada
sports es parte del negocio espacial y
de un vuelo de prueba en particular
estamos probando este cohete y la nave
espacial de una manera que nunca lo
harías con tripulación humana a bordo
y artemis uno tiene éxito artemis 2
despegará en 2024 y por primera vez una
mujer y una persona afro pisarán suelo
lunar en 2025
también será la prueba de que el sistema
de lanzamiento espacial funciona aquel
vehículo de lanzamiento que se encargará
de propulsar a la cápsula orion desde la
luna hacia el planeta marte